pflanzen im weltall oder frisches gemüse
auf der internationalen raumstation
das wird bald möglich sein meinen
wissenschaftler alles dazu jetzt in
kriegs und science fiction
jedes kilo nahrung dass in den orbit
transportiert wird kostet etwa 20.000
euro
bis es beim mars ist geht der preis
schon in die millionen
um unter anderem dieses problem zu lösen
forschen biologen physiker und sensorik
an pflanzen zum beispiel werden pflanzen
in einer speziellen vorrichtung zunächst
an der wand gepflanzt also in einer
horizontalen lage durch eine
durchgehende rotation
wer die pflanzen dann also um die eigene
achse wenn die pflanzen dazu gebracht
waagerecht zu wachsen
die drehung soll dabei die
schwerelosigkeit simuliert
das funktioniert weil zb dadurch stärke
körnchen der pflanze so herum
geschleudert werden dass sie ins trudeln
geraten und die zellwände erst gar nicht
berühren das bringt die pflanze so
durcheinander dass sie nicht mehr weiß
wo oben und unten ist also deshalb
wächst sie geradeaus in dem fall
horizontal von der wand hängen in ihren
versuchen an der universität hohenheim
hat alina schickt fallen mit
sonnenblumen gearbeitet allerdings
gesehen waagerecht das wachstum auch mit
hibiskus amaryllis und gummibäumen
gelungen die forschung an den horizont
pflanzen hat mehrere gründe zum einen
sind sie ein modisches accessoire für
ein haus oder eine wohnung zum anderen
ist die idee für die raumfahrt äußerst
interessant in bremen untersuchen
wissenschaftler ähnliche auswirkungen
auf pflanzen
sie haben das ferne ziel raumstationen
und astronauten mit grünzeug zu
versorgen
dabei spielt die ästhetik eine rolle
aber auch der kostenfaktor ist sehr
wichtig und die transportkosten von
spezialnahrung steigen ja mit der
entfernung dramatisch an es ist also
viel sinnvoller nur samen ins all zu
schicken und die pflanzen in der
schwerelosigkeit anzubauen
zudem sind pflanzen wichtig für die
psyche der drei jahre in einer
blechbüchse verbringt mit künstlichem
licht vielen kabeln und einem hohen
geräuschpegel der möchte wenigstens
etwas grünes um sich haben meint daniel
schubert vom deutschen zentrum für luft
und raumfahrt
der ingenieur der züchte deshalb mit
seinem team pflanzen die sich an
weltraumbedingungen angepasst haben
bislang ist es ihm gelungen salat
wachsen zu lassen
allerdings konnte dieser geschmackliche
nicht zum ganz überzeugen
bis die astronauten also frisches gemüse
pflanzen und ernten können wird es noch
etwas dauern
aber die ergebnisse der
forschungsarbeiten in hohenheim und
bremen können sich bereits gut sehen
lassen 2009 ist es alina schick schon
gelungen einen kirschbaum in einer
waschmaschinentrommel zu züchten
dieser wurde sogar einen meter 60 groß
ihr nächstes etappenziel ist es
horizontal wachsende bäume auf den markt
zu bringen
kostenpunkt 4000 euro natürlich werden
die pflanzen bisher nur unter
laborbedingungen gezüchtet das bedeutet
24 stunden am tag werden sie belichtet
die wasserversorgung wird
vollautomatisch mit computern geregelt
und schädlinge kommen erst gar nicht an
die pflanzen heran
deshalb wachsen sie sogar schneller als
sonst
bis die ersten tomaten gurken dann
allerdings im weltraum geerntet werden
können das dauert noch eine weile in die
ferne genau das pflanzenwachstum von
faktoren wie der schwerkraft oder der
rotation beeinflusst wird soll in der
nächsten zeit noch genauer erforscht
es könnte übrigens auch an einer anderen
stelle in unserem sonnensystem pflanzen
oder andere organismen geben aliens in
unseren gästen heißt das video zu diesem
thema hier klicken wenn euch das
interessiert im block und in der app
gibt es täglich mühe und auch die besten
wissenschafts videos auf youtube was
meint ihr würdet ihr euch eine
waagerecht wachsende pflanze an die wand
pflanzen einfach nur bullshit diskutiert
es mit mir in den kommentaren und ich
sag jetzt nur noch bis dann leiten